also haupt wahlsieger war die cdu vor
allem in ostdeutschland nicht sondern
wir haben in ostdeutschland ziemlich
deutlich verloren richtige klatsche
bekommen und der satz ist richtig man
kann nur im osten die wahlen nicht
gewinnen sondern kann sie im osten
verlieren und dabei ist für die analyse
wichtig dass wir stark verloren haben an
die spd wir haben in brandenburg und in
mecklenburg vorpommern vor vier jahren
alle wahlkreise gewonnen diesmal alle
wahlkreise an die spd verloren daran ist
aber nicht nur die spd schuld sondern da
müssen wir auch sehen wir müssen die afg
in dieser analyse einbeziehen denn zur
wahrheit gehört wir haben nicht nur
wähler an die spd und an die grünen
verloren im osten sondern wir haben
viele wähler von der ard die wir
eigentlich zurück gewinnen wollten und
die zurück gewinnbar sind das sind nicht
die verschwörungstheoretiker das sind
nicht die rechtsextremisten aber viele
leute die nicht mehr konsum die
konservativ denken die bei uns zu wenig
profil erkennen die haben wir nicht
zurück gewonnen wenn uns das gelungen
wäre werden viele wahlkreise im osten
nicht verloren gegangen und viele
kollegen die sehr verdient hätten wer
noch dabei ist und das geld der sich nur
für den osten ja was ist gerade im osten
das strategische thema das die
wahlkreise dort besonders knapp verloren
wurden weil wir eine situation dort
hatten die spd hat die wahlkreise
überwiegend ja nicht mit jubel
ergebnissen gewonnen sondern 25 26
prozent und dann 20 prozent ard 20
prozent cdu in vielen wahlkreisen und
bei diesen 20 prozent ab dem muss man
wissen viele protestwähler dabei viele
verschwörungs newsticker aber viele
frühere cdu stammwähler von denen es uns
nicht gelungen ist die wieder zurück zu
bekommen was eigentlich mein anspruch
war was uns in mecklenburg vorpommern
zwischen zwei 16 und 217 wieder gelungen
war und das hat diesmal nicht geklappt
und deswegen sage ich wenn man alleine
von den fdp wählern durch profil durch
klare sprache die nicht heißt ländern
die nicht heißt debatten irgendwie
darüber ob man jetzt im schulunterricht
fünfte sechste klasse denn dann anfängt
oder kostenloser op en v wo sich die
leute bei uns erfragen kommt der bus ein
zweites mal am tag in meinem dorf die
themen haben wir nicht richtig
adressiert ländlicher raum spielt in den
tri allen und in den kampagnen kaum eine
rolle wenn uns das gelungen wer bin ich
fest überzeugt hätten wir von den 20
prozent fd bestimmt 45 überziehen können
von leuten die von uns enttäuscht und
dann wäre die wahl im osten ganz anders
ausgegangen also diese analyse deckt
sich mit meinen beobachtungen
ferndiagnose gab die cdu hat einen
unglaublichen kapital fehler gemacht vor
ein paar jahren war sie hat sich nie
zugelassen dass das gefühl entstehen
konnte dass eigentlich in diesen neuen
bundesländern mehr oder weniger alles
nazis zu hause sind dies nicht etwa 150
prozent einverstanden sind mit der
migrationspolitik in berlin das ist eine
ganz gefährliche da kommt so ein
bisschen herrenreiter die tüte aus
berlin rein und ich muss sagen ich aus
schweizer ich habe größten respekt vor
diesen leuten aus den neuen
bundesländern eine das sind leute die
sind ja vor die gewehrläufe der
nationalen volksarmee gestand das sind
ja freiheitskämpfer das sind leute die
sozusagen auf grund ihrer leidens vollen
erfahrung unter der knute dieser ganzen
sowjetischen kommunistischen diktatur
gewisse freiheits und innen entwickelt
haben und ich würde mir eigentlich
wünschen für die cdu ich glaube ihr habt
eine riesen chance ihr müsst doch da die
hand ausstrecken und nicht sich die
schuhe putzen und dort habt frau merkel
das ist mein eigentlich größter vor
rufen sie ich finde frau merkel hat ein
paar fehler gemacht natürlich aber ich
fand sie lange eine sehr beeindruckende
persönlichkeit 8 uhr ihre
unaufgeregtheit durch ihren sehr
pragmatischen ich weiß es gibt leute in
deutschland oder hast du die merkel
nicht loben dann bist du gleich unten
durch aber da hat sie einen kapitalen
fehler gemacht wie sie dort reagiert hat
2018 wie sie über diese ostdeutschen in
anführungszeichen hinweg gefahren ist
der hauptmann der kfd geradezu die leute
zu getrieben in scharen unnötig ihre
analyse stimmt jetzt müssen sie einfach
herum tue es müssen sie hier der neue
versöhnen die mutter teresa der neuen
lkw
fahren muss
nicht nur die bundes cdu hatten
katastrophales ergebnis eingefahren
sondern sie mit ihrer cdu in mecklenburg
vorpommern ja auch also haben sie ja
auch selbst eine menge verantwortung
daran zu tragen ja auch als ost-cdu
absolut und es war eine mecklenburg
vorpommern auch zwei zusammenkommen
defekte wir hatten parallel die
landtagswahlen manuela schwesig hohe
beliebtheitswerte und ich musste auch
anerkennt sagen sehr professionelle
kampagne von ihr fehlerfrei gemacht
wirklich ein starker wahlkampf der
ministerpräsidentin das war der eine
fakt sie hat gesagt wer manuela schwesig
will muss spd wählen das hat der spd
auch bei der bundestagswahl geholfen war
für uns negativtrend und dann der
allgemeine trend der cdu bundespolitisch
der gegen den osten lief und da finde
ich richtig müssen wir auch hinterfragen
warum wir da vielleicht nicht klar
adressieren bei michael kretschmer
reiner haseloff superminister pavlik
drei wahlen verloren die sache berlin
schuldig ob damit gar nicht will dann
hat michael kretschmer und reiner
haseloff gehören auch zu denen die
glaube ich immer wieder diese themen
adressiert haben dass haseloff so stark
gewonnen hat in sachsen anhalt lag auch
daran dass er nicht versucht hat der
berliner twitter community zu gefallen
und den samtsofa im prenzlauer berg
sondern lebensrealität in magdeburg und
halle und im ländlichen raum zu
adressieren so und dann müssen wir schon
hinterfragen warum ist uns das nicht
besser gelungen und die beschreibung des
ostens auch in vielen teilen der
medienlandschaft ist ein riesenproblem
weil wenig laut genug widersprechen es
ist ja so der eindruck die wahlkreise
die an die fdp gehen da entsteht ja so
ein druck da wohnen jetzt eine
rechtsradikale und da muss man da mal
sagen wenn wenn denn wahllokal irgendwie
25 fd und teilweise mehr wenn da jeder
vierte die afg wählt dann sind das nicht
irgendwelche versprengten
verschwörungstheoretiker sondern sind
ganz normale menschen die sich nicht
mehr angesprochen fühlen von dem wie wir
in berlin-mitte diskutieren
ich hoffe dass mich bewegt diese
diskussion weil weil ich einfach größten
respekt habe von diesen leuten in der
neuen bundesland ich meine denen ist ja
quasi die mussten und bei einem
fürchterlichen regime leben und dann hat
man ihnen quasi noch einmal den boden
unter den füßen weggezogen wir haben
damals viele leute im osten gesagt
wissen sie ich finde das fürchterlich
wie wir ändert werden die aus berlin so
etwas ist einfach nicht akzeptabel war
das was uns irritiert jetzt haben wir
einfach leute erzählt damals die haben
wissen sie uns hat man immer gesagt wir
müssen uns einschränken
wir müssen sparen wir haben nicht die d
mark bekommen wir müssen jetzt sozusagen
in dieser neuen welt ankommen und uns
einschränken wir haben das gemacht und
plötzlich hat man mit dieser ganzen
migrationswelle da die schranken
geöffnet da ist der sozialstaat
plötzlich für alle da sind wir
eigentlich menschen zweiter klasse
und da habe ich in berlin damals ich war
einige mal in berlin festgestellt dass
beide cdu bei frau merkel unverständlich
sie kommt ja sie ist gebiet und ich
glaube sie hauptsache verstanden sie
hätten es verstanden aber ich habe nicht
begriffen warum die cdu damals derart
also fast arrogant gewirkt hat eben
vielleicht auch etwas nacht betrunken
hat man geglaubt die sich so profilieren
zu müssen ich finde jetzt ihre analyse
liegen wie wohltuend unter scheint mir
schon irgendwo der weg zu sein für mich
hat die cdu eine riesige chance wenn sie
sich wieder so aufstellt wie sich
vielleicht einmal gewesen ist und auch
die konservativen wähler nicht einfach
pauschal
abqualifizieren da lassen wir uns auf
den türen ein glaube ich die frage ist
halt nur dass es gerade schon gesagt es
geht darum wieder zurückzuholen wir
sprechen dabei schon sehr sehr lange
vorn wir tun es nicht es passiert nicht
so glaubst du das ändert sich oder waren
trauen wir uns wieder über themen zu
sprechen wie mit migrations nur
weiterhin zunehmen werde auch nichts
vorwärts gesehen bedacht mit afghanistan
wann über themen wie stärkung der
leistungsträger hat inzwischen das
gefühl wenn man über
leistungsbereitschaft spricht wird man
abqualifizieren ja weil das nicht dem
aktuellen zeitgeist entspricht was ich
super schade finde aber wie geht's ja
also ich glaube es beginnt mit der
analyse und dann nervt mich offen
gesprochen dass uns jetzt wieder dann
die demoskopen rauf und runter
vorrechnen unser problem sei nur dass
wir wähler verloren hätten an die spd
und die grünen und eine bestätigung
suchen haben die lasche links hunden
oder ich bin mit den gedanken jetzt zu
ende führen dass wir sagen wir hätten
nur links die wähler verloren das
problem ist dass wir jetzt abgehakt
haben schon die wähler die wir vor
vielen jahren verloren haben die früher
mal cdu-stammwähler waren die wir nicht
mehr erreicht haben weil das bürgerlich
konservative element zu schwach
ausgeprägt ist und da will ich die immer
noch nicht verloren geben soll ich
glaube die sind noch zurückgewinnen und
das geht übrigens nicht dadurch dass es
eine wonne zur lösung gibt sage ich für
mich persönlich auch ich glaube wir
müssen einfach unterschiedlichen
wahlkampf führen unterschiedliche bilder
auch sehen für ostdeutschland für den
ländlichen raum für die städte für den
obama muss man einfach breite zu lassen
und deswegen kann ich auch damit leben
dass dann mancher in
berlin-friedrichshain mich nicht so gut
findet und die leute dafür beim
schützenverein in ueckermünde gut finden
wir sparen das interessiert mich jetzt
noch bevor er weiter in der diskussion
gehen was sagen die leute wenn sie durch
friedrichshain laufen werfen die mit
irgendetwas ganz bestimmt nicht ich habe
meine wahlkreis tausch gemacht mit der
changan bayram war so ein format die
hier in berlin irgendwo hier in mitte
irgendwo in den wahlkreis direkt
gewonnen hat da den strömenden nachfolge
bei kreis und ich kann es mal so sagen
wenn man sich das angeguckt hat tat sie
sich bei der feuerwehr ist wer im
ländlichen raum wo sie dann mal sah wie
das ist wenn dir kein internet hast ja
und da sind weite wege sind seine vom
bahnhof nicht mehr auto abgeholt wird
hat sie sich offensichtlich schwerer als
ich jetzt in friedrich sein wobei die
mir da jetzt auch nicht zugejubelt haben
muss ich auch mal sagen aber deswegen
finde ich auch da es ist doch auch gut
und gehört auch zur wahrheit dass du am
kottbusser tor andere politik
erwartungen hast als irgendwie bei der
feuerwehr an der polnischen grenze und
das muss man vielleicht auch ein
bisschen darstellen und auch mal
aushalten politisch habe er das ja
soviel wähler verloren habt allein die
ich ja schon sage ihr so viele wähler
verloren das ist der graben zwischen
bürgern und politik den die politik auch
mit einer arroganz macht und du verpasst
das finde ich auch in einem
eingangsdaten gemacht obwohl du sie
nicht mal wird der satz du hast gesagt
viele kollegen die sehr verdient gehabt
hätten wäre noch dabei gewesen da muss
ich sagen so viele kollegen ist verloren
habe es nicht geschafft haben die bürger
mit leidenschaft wenn sie so schlecht
gearbeitet haben aber das war wieder der
satz weswegen man das gefühl hat es geht
um passten ja aber monet und sagt also
erstmalig kam es aber milliarden waren
okay und er bestätigt aber ich bin ja
auch wählerinnen ich glaube die politik
die bürger haben nicht mehr das gefühl
und allein schon dass ich jetzt sage die
bürger als wäre ich nicht aber also ich
als bürgerin habe nicht mehr das gefühl
dass die politik sich überhaupt nur noch
ein paar sich erlauben mir nur die
emotionale
das ist das eine war wenn du am
wahlsonntag gesehen hast gut 49 kollegen
weniger dann ist erst mal eine zahl ja
aber wenn man jetzt diese tage im
bundestag wiederkommt und dann sieht
dass ein kollege von mir aus halle den
ich sehr schätze mit dem innenausschuss
super zusammengearbeitet habe dass der
dann die da nicht drin ist auch wegen
des trends opulent ob wahlkampf gemacht
hat andere kollegen mehr bin sei es die
emotionale bemerkung dass ich scheiße
finde man will haben wir weiter sprechen
über porsche mancher dieses cdu krimi
und nena stinkt's lieblingsthema corona
und karl lauterbach alters nach der
werbung
[Musik]